[Music]
foreign as always at this time of the
evening it is the Press preview first
look at what is on tomorrow's front
pages and tonight we'll see what's
making the headlines for the broadcaster
and former conservative special advisor
Anita botang who's joined by the
journalist and also Rachel shall be a
very good evening to you we'll speak in
a moment after we've checked out those
front pages for you and we're going to
begin with the Observer revealed 30
billion pound cost of disastrous trust
budget is their headline as the paper
looks at the financial impact of the
former prime minister's mini budget
Richie revives thatcherism to rescue UK
reads the headline of the Sunday Express
as it preempts the prime minister's tax
plans
while the Sunday Telegraph analyzes the
proposed government policies towards
Asylum Seekers their headline 10-point
migration plan to end Hotel Britain
and the Sunny Times turns to liberated
hairson in Ukraine with the headline
Putin's Retreat transforms Chaos on into
a city of joy
former Health secretary Matt Hancock
makes the front of the Sunday Mirror
during one of his I'm a celebrity trials
and he's also pictured on the front of
the Daily Star Sunday
and don't forget you can scan the QR
code that you see on screen during the
program uh check out the front pages of
Sunday's papers while you watch us
discussing them and I'm joined by Anita
and Rachel great to have you with us
this Saturday evening lots to talk about
and we're going to start with uh what
might be in Thursday's Autumn statement
Anita the front of the Sunday Express
Rishi revives factorism to rescue UK the
Sunday Times also has done an interview
with the chancellor what can we expect
well this story touches on the famous
words of thatchera she was trying to get
down inflation say you know there is no
alternative and I think that's very much
been the theme and mood music coming out
of HMT and number 10 ever since Rishi
sunak became prime minister I think he
and Jeremy Hunt are very well aware of
the very difficult decisions that
they're going to have to make and what
they're doing here is preparing the
country for what might come and we have
some early indications some early
reports of what might perhaps be in that
Autumn statement one of which is kind of
considerable phrases of thresholds
um around things such as um taxation so
at the moment um those taxation
thresholds kind of go up with inflation
um but what if they are held static then
lots more people will end up in higher
tax brackets and that of course means
more revenue for the exchequer it's one
of the more discrete ways of raising a
lot of money because quite a few people
will be affected by it and given the
situation the tough hand they've been
dealt it feels like one of the one of
the only options available to them
really
um to help address the amount of money
that they need to find Rachel I've had a
brief look at the interview in in the
Sunday Times and something struck me as
quite interesting he says that trust and
quote had the right idea about growth
but were wrong to act without showing we
can pay our way as a country wrong not
to have those obr forecasts what did you
make of that and what else you have to
say
well I think he's alluding there to the
fact that the you know the markets
reacted so badly to carsonomics because
it wasn't costed so there was you know
they just didn't show their sums and so
the market panicked as a response to
that but I do think this whole narrative
it's it's completely false it's
unnecessary there is an alternative
um there are plenty of Alternatives and
it's absolutely absurd and negligent and
dangerous to plunge this country and to
get another round of austerity we cannot
take another round of that we're already
broken by the the 12 years of austerity
so far and when you look at you know
there's so many other ways of doing this
and it's worth looking at why why
recovery in the UK is so slow compared
to other G7 countries what are we doing
that other countries are not doing
because that obviously is going to shed
some live on the problem here and so yes
that thing beginning with b is a factor
but it's obviously not the only Factor
because things have been bad in this
country way before brexit people were
struggling so what are the Alternatives
Rachel then just very briefly what do
you think the alternatives are okay so
let's look at the Alternatives one of
the things that other countries do is
that they're far less real they're far
more relaxed about this fiscal black
hole which is quite an arbitrary thing
Progressive economic Forum have
explained and it's been covered picked
up by the BBC this week that is quite an
arbitrary limit that government has
imposed on itself that other governments
in Europe do not do the second thing is
that you can look at raising revenue in
different ways you don't have to cut
um public services and Welfare you can
generate taxes 37 billion according to
chat Justice UK by taxing wealth in the
same way that you tax
um wages so if you tax profits and wage
accumulation from the very top
percentage of our society
um and equalize try and equalize those
things you're actually going to raise 37
billion which is very close so even in
the government's own terms of having to
fill this black hole that would do it
the government is choose not to do that
that's a choice okay I'm going to get
Anita's view on that because your eyes
seem to be getting wider and wider I
could see on my monitor here Anita we're
very relaxed about the fiscal Black Hole
uh says says Rachel what'd you make of
it well I I think we had a prime
minister who tried to be relaxed about
the physical back hole and the market
said otherwise I completely accept that
um markets at the moment are incredibly
antsy and they are looking at countries
that are trying to do things differently
and they're incredibly nervous about
countries that are doing things
differently so I think it's an enormous
gamble to be talking about um having a
different approach to fiscal black holes
I mean I I and also on the question of
world taxes ultimately you know Rachel
was left-wing is going to have that
point of view um and I think actually
things like capital gains tax which is
one of the things that Jeremy Hunt is
rumored to be looking at that is a
similar look at what what you can do to
raise revenue from people but gain a lot
um who have a lot um from capital gains
but the reality is that one percent of
the population paid 30 of income tax
like the the tax burden is primarily
carried by wealthy people and my
businesses and we crucially need
business investment one of the things I
do agree with Rachel and I'm trying to
find some is the that this country has
had a challenge in recovering from
economic difficulties for quite a long
time it stems back to 2008 but actually
it Stones back further than that to some
of the structural challenges around
productivity in our economy but the
truth is there are no easy answers to
those questions and it is very much the
reason why for instance the labor party
isn't saying look there is an easy
solution and I think we've learned and
we should have learned from the past few
months that we should be very very
skeptical of the idea of easy solutions
to how we can fund and grow our economy
okay I want to squeeze in another couple
of stories so we're going to move on if
we may um front of the Sunday Times uh
remarkable scenes today Rachel uh our
correspondent Alex Rossi the first
International journalist into her song
he was getting hugged soldiers were
getting hugged and you can see from the
front of the Sunday Times Smiles of Joy
on people's faces there
yeah it was really emotional a movie
watching those scenes with Alex as you
say on the streets of Ukraine and the
incredible welcome he received and it's
just great frankly to have this bit of
good news isn't it um just in general
but also in particular in Ukraine where
all we've had is just horrendous news of
what people were dealing with
um and this is just uh you know after
eight months of occupation Russian
occupation
um Russia hastily fled on Friday morning
but apparently inside Russia is trying
to paint this as a strategic withdrawal
not buying it doesn't really look very
strategic when you leave so abruptly and
it's going to be a huge blow for Putin
potentially one of the biggest blows
he's had to deal with the times has
certainly painted it painting it as such
um in terms of the damage to his own
reputation and standing but as you say
wonderful to see that celebration on the
streets of her son and it must be just a
huge relief after what people in that
City have been dealing with for the past
few months yeah absolutely um let's move
on to the front of the mirror a very
different story but it's still something
lots of people are talking about uh the
headline Hancock hasn't got a prayer I'm
not sure the Reverend Max drink water
when he made these comments was
expecting to be on the front page of the
paper
what have you made Anita of the last
sort of 48 Hours of of Matt Hancock in
this reality show
oh gosh I haven't seen any of it I've
ever seen it I'm so sorry I've not seen
I'm a celebrity but I do think um I have
seen a couple of the choice clips of of
Matt singing in the jungle
um look I think that it's always really
challenging when you're doing a job
right now and you you do things like
this because even if there is a point
about showing you know yourself as a
well-rounded individual at the moment
you are still a sitting NP look I wish
Matt well
um but but I think that this is a very
very challenging thing from the
perspective of the public and I imagine
doing a show such as that I I think
he'll struggle to sort of win people
over
um and I'm not yet sure how much has
been mentioned because I think dyslexia
was one of the things that he wanted to
bring up quite a lot
um during in the jungle and talk about
his own struggles with that I haven't
seen reports yet of in-depth discussions
about that so I hope to see those in due
course yeah Rachel the vicar in his
constituency saying rmp has clearly
neglected his constituents by going into
the jungle
kind of amusing to see this end up in a
Suffolk Vicar's sermon right that is
just funny uh but he is the Victor vicar
making a serious point which is that it
is neglecting his constituency is paid
to do a job that he's clearly not doing
and I also just think this is a really
disgraceful attempt to rehabilitate his
reputation which should be in tatters
and you know he should be scrutinized
over the many mistakes that he made
deadly mistakes in the mismanagement of
the kovid crisis and over which many
many families across the country will
feel that he never really faced the
scrutiny that he deserves yeah he's
certainly getting hauled over the coals
isn't he by some of the other uh
contestants in in that show okay both
thank you very much coming up in a
moment we'll have a look through some of
the other stories making papers
and Rachel don't go away
thank you
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview still with me Anita boteng and
Rachel shabby let's turn to the front of
the Sunday Telegraph shall we Rachel
some pretty Punchy headlines actually on
the front of the telegraph including
this one nurses unreasonable pay demand
will raise inflation
yeah I mean this is according to the
health secretary and um you know I it's
interesting to see uh what nurses are
asking for and they've just obviously
voted to go on strike being described in
those terms I suspect that the health
secretary is going to find himself
distinctly out of kilter with the public
mood and particularly after the pandemic
when we saw the incredible work that
nurses and other healthcare workers did
in this country and how essential and
valued that was
um just to put it into context I mean
nurses are there's been 40 000 nurses
who have left uh the preference
profession in the last year burn out too
stressful
um
post-traumatic stress presumably after
dealing with a pandemic one in eight
nurses is using a food bank one in three
is struggling uh to pay for food and
heating I don't think any of this paints
a picture of an unreasonable demand
especially when you put it in the
context of you know when you actually
listen to nurses talk about this
they actually fear for the future of the
NHS they worry that current Staffing
conditions and are putting
um putting patients at risk and the
decision to strike is as much informed
by that as it is by the other factors we
just mentioned Anita
well I think that 17 and a half
plea I thought that what a government is
saying is
it's affordable we're in a situation
where
um there were widespread concerns and in
fact opposition from labor to the
increase in National Insurance which was
going to impart fund an increase in NHS
we've talked about the um turmoil we see
in the market and could continue to see
unless we find a way of of bringing the
country back into the black in terms of
fiscal rectitude that is
um and also we are facing an incredibly
difficult winter
um where demand for the NHS is higher
than ever we have seven million on our
waiting lists
um and funding for the NHS has is going
to be tightly um squeezed and if that
goes on pay I can understand I mean
we're streeting the the health Shadow
and health secretary
um also said he wouldn't be able to
offer a 17 and a half percent it's
simply not affordable
um so I can completely understand why
nurses themselves
um feel very strongly they should have a
significant pay rise I also understand
deeply why the government is saying
unfortunately we cannot afford this
um and and pay Rises such as this would
feel inflation I'm afraid these are just
the facts um and so I really hope we see
a a clear a resolution to this but and I
do imagine the public has a lot a great
deal of sympathy but I also know that
you're in politics to make tough
decisions and these are kind of
decisions I would expect from the health
secretary yeah we're approaching the end
of the house but I do want to squeeze
this in it's sort of related actually
it's a pace story on the front of the
Observer Rachel and this is interesting
isn't it people in professional
occupations from working class families
earn thousands of pounds a year Less on
average for doing the same job as their
more privileged peers
that's right this is from the social
Mobility Foundation just under 7 000
less a year for doing exactly the same
job as you say professional manager of
jobs which make up 30 of jobs in the UK
and the things that are causing this
um so this is for people from working
class backgrounds but women and ethnic
minorities are double hit in this
context it's the what's described as the
brute force in this piece of Parental
wealth so that sort of insulates people
from the sort of risk taking that you
need early in the career so that you can
you know you take low paid insecure jobs
to facilitate well-paid jobs in the
future and also just being able to get
on the property ladder earlier because
of family well so those are the two
things that are
um thought to be contributing to this
huge wealth Gap from Tomorrow People for
working class backgrounds in those
sectors are working for free Anita very
quick thought from you on this
I mean this is remarkable and I think it
we really should engage a lot more about
the intersection between class and
ethnicity and um and gender because
um a lot of the time focus on there's no
dichotomy that's created between the
idea of the working class and other
other protected groups but actually I
think when the two combine it can be
greatly exacerbated so I think this is a
really important piece of work yeah
really interesting isn't it and you can
read more about that in tomorrow's
Observer Anita Rachel thank you both for
the moment we'll speak again